your old man was a piece of work the
most you know you know my father was
arrested for three major felonies in
three different decades geez like 76
somewhere in the 80s and then somewhere
in the 2000s I can't remember it was
crazy always heavy basically dealing
drugs to make money what was it like for
him as he started to see you succeed as
a musician do you think he envied you
that was that was a bad scene
oh it was bad it was bad it was he got
really jealous
it was I I was shocked
because you know in my mind you know
it's like yeah I watched too many Disney
movies but I thought he would Pat me on
the head and say good job kid I'm so
proud of you it was the exact opposite
it was like he acted like I played some
weird magic trick and I got lucky and he
would use words like lucky and save your
money because you're gonna need it and
snug a knuckle in the last it was all
this Doom talk
so he put all that Vibe on me but it was
the album Siamese Dream I think he
listened to the album and he called me
afterwards and said I don't know who
this person is singing this album like I
want to know is that you in there like
and he gave me this weird talk like like
is that who you really are and I was
like yes it's me I've been here the
whole time hello it's your son you know
Bill hello yeah he acted like I was a
total stranger and they tried to tell me
weird [__] like you were so quiet as a
kid and I said no because every time I
opened my mouth you told me to shut the
[__] up
so then I just took the note like a
quick story my father was really good at
working on cars and like a little boy I
wanted to be close to my dad so bad I
would just go sit in the garage while he
worked on a car just to be near him and
he wouldn't even talk to me or look at
me because I just wanted anything from
him just to be in his proximity and then
the years later he tell me these stories
like oh I don't remember that or you
know I'd be like what are you talking
about it's like so weird it is so weird
but here's the crazy thing so like after
he died I went to his his house to kind
of his wife let me rummage through his
stuff and pick some of the stuff I
wanted and next to his bed was
uh the lyric book from melancholy
and it was really weathered
and his wife said he used to just sit in
bed and listen to this album and read
the lyrics
and it's like how is the guy who tells
me Shut the [__] up I don't want I don't
want to hear anything you have to say
man it's crazy to his eternal credit we
had many conversations before he died
and he he said I really underestimated
you and now I now I get it and I
understand and I realize how great you
are but if I got that from him it was a
little too late I got it
foreign